alors
oh
ah ah
[Musique]
barbara cassin est ce qu'on peut dire
que la france c'est une langue une
littérature oui sûrement ça et c'est
aussi un pays oui mais
c'est vrai qu'un pays c'est un pays par
sa langue way est une langue c'est des
auteurs et des oeuvres ouais donc par sa
littérature par sa philosophie des
cartes il fait partie de la littérature
voilà parce qu'on écrit en français oui
et pas seulement en france oui alors il
ya leur donnant ce de villers cotterêts
qu'évidemment oui a marqué notre
histoire
vous parliez des cartes aussi des cartes
c'est c'est l'esprit on dit souvent
l'esprit cartésien c'est l'esprit
français c'est vrai ou pas ça j'en sais
rien je veux dire c'est très beau
le bon sens est la chose du monde la
mieux partagée pour parfait on sait pas
trop ce que ça veut dire m'enfin bon
c'est un manifeste liberté égalité
fraternité au fond vous vous êtes membre
de l'académie française je connais peu
d'autres pays enfin à ma connaissance
qui attachent autant d'importance
justement à une institution pareil qui
est en fait la l'académie française est
née là pour défendre cette langue ce qui
prouve quand même qu'on y attache
beaucoup d'importance et la patrie quoi
absolument absolument ça je pense que là
il ya un lien très fort pour l'académie
française est là comme la comédie
française comme la bibliothèque de
france le dira d un grande institution
on sait et ça fait partie des fondations
de de la nation justement française
de la nation je ne sais pas
enfin je pense qu'il y aurait la france
sans l'académie française c'est vrai oui
d'accord mais je pense que c'est
remarquablement
liés à
ce qu'est la langue française comme
politique je pense que la langue en
france ça a toujours été quelques chose
de politique vous évoquez hilare
cauterets c'est le cas bien sûr
évidemment cette ordonnance qui dit que
en langage maternelle france et non
autrement voilà à juger on comprendra
jugement qu'on porte sur vous et que ça
sera pas du latin et que ça sera pas non
plus
du grimoire incompréhensible c'est
formidable et vous dites c'est un outil
finalement politiques la langue et
pourtant on se sert assez peu de la
francophonie finalement non ça peut-être
pas assez enfin son rêve ou le déplorer
je trouve que c'est fondamental la
francophonie et c'est fondamental
la diversité du français à l'intérieur
et à l'extérieur mais il ya un
dictionnaire des francophones qui est
qui a vu le jour oui très beau oui
et c'est justement la délégation
générale à la langue française et aux
langues de france avec ce petit
redoublement la whey qui est là la
patronne de cette chose là donc oui je
trouve ça très très intéressant le dit
le dictionnaire de l'académie française
qui maintenant est sur le net et c'est
trés et très émouvant parce que il y est
depuis le premier dictionnaire jusqu'à
maintenant oui et ce que je trouve très
beau dans tout ça c'est que quand c'est
fini on recommence ça veut dire que la
langue c'est pas un truc figé oui voilà
donc en fait on dit que l'académie
française est la gardienne de la langue
française mais la laisse évoluer aussi l
est pas là pour nous de toute façon la
langue se débrouille tout seul avec ou
sans academy et la langue appartient aux
français on va écouter quelqu'un qui
qu'il pensait sans doute regarder
je me fais en effet de la france une
certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je ne pense ressentie par
le monde entier
c'est vrai la france est une chose à mes
yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quels
qu'ils soient toutes époques
naturellement d'après les circonstances
elle doit avoir un rôle elle
il faut que la france joue son rôle
c'est exact et pour qu'elle joue son
rôle il faut qu'elle soit la france
les français les français ceux qui font
la france
c'est lui qui en sont responsables
la france est plus que les français du
moment
la france vient de loin
alors il y beaucoup de choses il parle
du rôle de la france a un côté très
littéraire d'ailleurs dans cette réponse
on étend en 1965 qui répond à michel
droit on est entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle la première au
suffrage universel direct
la france vient de loin elle vient d'où
la france pour vous
mais déjà j'aurais envie de dire que ce
qu'ils racontent oui là c'est du grand
art ah oui c'était alors que
ces salaires tellement naturel tellement
évident pour lui tellement profond ça
vient d'eux ça vient de ses tripes si
j'avais à dire et en même temps
il ne dit pas grand chose oui il dit en
gros la france est la france oui c'est
ça ouais
et bien d'où la france pour vous pour
vous personnellement pour moi
elle ya d'ailleurs parce que mes parents
venaient d'ailleurs vrai que
pour moi la france c'est vraiment une
terre d'accueil ouais et c'est comme ça
qu'il faut qu'elles le soient et quels
le reste alors
le père de ma mère était hongrois ouais
et du côté de mon père il était d'abord
barbaresques way turcs italiens juive du
pape enfin bon d'accord et français tout
ça c'est de la france c'est de
l'assimilation
oui c'est de là on peut appeler ça
simulation c'est pas un très joli mot ça
fait un peu digestion comme ça n'ont
cessé de la variété à ça pour moi la
france ce qui singularise la france
précisément ce que j'aimerais soit ouais
c'est c'est la division que je donne
d'ailleurs de la traduction c'est un
savoir faire avec les différences c'est
ça que je voudrais qu'elle soit alors
bon il ya des pays qui le sont plus ou
moins chaque fois que j'arrive en france
je trouve que c'est plutôt bien fait
mais c'est plutôt heureux mais
par rapport à un nom savoir faire avec
les différences du genre de l'inde
d'aujourd'hui l'un d'eux maudit on
voulait dire qu'il est extrêmement
nationaliste c'est terrifiant et très
anti quelque chose est très
oui très
regroupés sur une tradition très
exclusive la nationalisme c'est la
guerre pour vous comme disait françois
mitterrand oui je suis assez d'accord
enfin en tout cas
si surtout si vous ajoutez isme le
nationalisme serait beau la nation c'est
autre chose oui et la nation la nation
en france c'est une réalité vous en
connaissez je sais pas trop ce que ça
veut dire ah bon novembre tu sais pas
trop ce que ça veut dire parce que pour
moi nation j'entends quand même le latin
ça va on est là ouais bon c'est très
bien c'est le droit du sol et pas le
droit du sang nenê mais quand on vient
d'ailleurs on n'est pas né là et on est
quand même français oui alors ça se
passe comment bon je sais que vous
intéresser beaucoup à la grèce
l'histoire grecque à la grèce antique et
il ya des origines grecques à notre pays
qui sont peut-être pas suffisamment
souligné régulièrement on parle beaucoup
des origines chrétiennes et des origines
gréco romaine est aussi évidemment oui
marseille
antibes tout ça sont aussi des cités qui
veut la glace oui mais on parlait de la
langue tout à l'heure la langue
française est là aussi en elle la langue
grecque et la langue latine de grecs
elle a peut-être la démocratie
heureusement que la démocratie française
n'est pas la démocratie grecque c'est à
dire qu'il ya pas d'esclaves et pas de
femmes qui ne votent pas ouais bon
l'époque n'est plus tout à fait la même
mais
il ya quand même la liberté de parole et
l'égalité de parole ça c'était ça qui
constituaient le coeur de la démocratie
une fois qu'on avait exclu tout ce qui
ne pouvait pas parler en grèce bon donc
aujourd'hui ce choeur là il est grec
le coeur de la démocratie parlante il y
vit plus encore que la tint bon mais ce
qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est la
manière dont la langue française à être
plein de grecs avec plein de latin et ça
ça me plaît et ce qui me déprime c'est
qu'on n'enseigne pas alors justement way
up l'enseignement des langues que les
langues dites anciennes donc le grec et
le latin qui était assez courant au
siècle dernier est encore dans la
première moitié du siècle dernier
aujourd'hui c'est quasiment
délaissé vous le regrettez ça oui je le
regarde beaucoup parce que moi ça m'a
appris immensément disons que c'est la
première fois que j'ai pu faire du j'ai
pu faire de l'anglais j'ai pu faire de
la demande italienne mais quand j'ai
fait du grec c'était la première fois
que j'ai compris ce que c'était une
langue autre vraiment et donc que moi
j'avais une langue il faut il faut
savoir connaître au moins deux langues
pour savoir qu'on en a une là vraiment
m'est apparu là à la fois la force et la
faiblesse du français par rapport aux
grecs et ça c'est passionnant et alors
justement c'était pas une insularité
française parce que dans beaucoup de
pays européens on apprenait le grec et
le latin
c'est la mondialisation qui a tout rasé
je dirais fait que on abandonne ses
langues anciennes pour apprendre des
langues étrangères
je ne sais pas c'est les utilitaires je
dirais peut-être
ça dépend utilisèrent pourquoi je veux
dire l'utilité de l'unique hills et
c'est génial et on en a besoin de
l'inutile le grec ancien est inutile et
prodigieusement utiles pour progresser
il faut connaître un peu les origines y
compris de sa langue c'est même pas
parce que les origines c'est parce que
c'est une langue magnifique que les
textes sont magnifiques et que on n'y a
pas du tout accès gepam aussi je lis
le début de l'ethique à nicomaque
d'aristote aristote la morale d'aristote
le lit en français c'est nul absolument
ça n'a aucun sens aucun intérêt aucun
aucune consistance
donc je lis en grec et là je commence à
comprendre comment les mots sont
fabriqués comment les phrases sont
fabriqués comment les idées sont
fabriqués et et c'est ça que j'aime
alors s'il ya plus de grec et de latin
plus tellement c'est aussi une
responsabilité politique oui est ce que
les politiques justement ne façonne pas
la culture d'un pays instrumentalise
d'une certaine façon son histoire la
façon de former les esprits oui tout à
fait sûr mais la politique et
l'éducation et la politique et la langue
évidemment tout ça et enfin
incroyablement et briquet ouais donc ou
bien sûr que oui maintenant ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que
il m'est arrivé de faire des bouts de
grecs avec des enfants qui a priori non
n'aurait jamais fait de leur vie et il
s'est toujours passé quelque chose c'est
à dire que c'est vraiment une langue
magnifique qui fait comprendre des
choses qu'on ne comprend pas autrement
voilà par exemple si je vous dis ça
l'air idiot comme ça au lieu de vous
dire bonjour je vous dis kaïré khairi ça
veut dire réjouis-toi jouit c'est une
manière d'ouvrir le monde qui est quand
même pas tout à fait la même et bien
chance un magnifique ouais mais ceci dit
toutes les manières d'ouvrir le monde
sont magnifiques simplement le fait
qu'elle soit différent c'est déjà
magnifique le fait qu'on puisse dire
salam shalom et que ça valide et que la
paix soit avec toi c'est magnifique bon
c'est cette différence là qui est
magnifique est ce que la france respecte
suffisamment les différents c'est
différent cela justement on ne respecte
jamais assez je croirais
mais enfin c'est sûr que le français
peut être une patrie commune ceux qui
sont en france d'accord alors l or il y
en a certains qui refusent cette
justement cette ce côté patriotique
cette histoire aussi parce qu'on vient
d'une histoire et qui la remettent en
question aujourd'hui
quel regard vous portez sur justement
tous ceux qui devraient effacer certains
pans de notre notre passé et jugent
indigne pas moral
par les genres boucle le guen c'est la
culture aussi c'est à dire on déplace
moi j'ai une expérience tout à fait
précise qui est l'afrique du sud j'ai
beaucoup travaillé en afrique du sud
s'est réveillée au tour de la commission
vérité réconciliation
c'est donc après l'apartheid l apartheid
au moment où mandela y avait 90 voilà au
moment où mandela est arrivé au pouvoir
et y avait un musée absolument atroce
bon qui représentait les sous-hommes
qu'étaient les noirs les écueils san
c'est à dire les peuples premiers et
c'est s'était
amusé à la madame tussauds mais horrible
l'amusé d'apartheid et alors qu'est ce
qu'a fait mandela il a mis au milieu de
la salle de ces énormes ça il a mis un
petit écriteau avec que pensez vous de
ce que vous voyez ça c'est génial un
rapport qualité prix on n'a jamais fait
mieux que pensez vous de ce que vous
voyez c'est quand même autrement mieux
que de déboulonner la statue de colbert
donc il faut pas effacer mais au
contraire james hook et il faut la seule
chose qu'on puisse enseigner aux gens à
mon avis dès le jugement oui donc
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ce que vous voyez mais jugé
et ça
est-ce qu'on peut pas le faire
aujourd'hui ce que les politiques ne
peuvent pas justement être plus actifs
là dessus pour essayer de contrer plutôt
que de s'indigner de contrer ceux qui
voudraient tout remettre en question oui
enfin c'est tout remettre à torcy où là
c'est pas la même chose il faut bien
s'indigner de j'entendais un bon mais
remettre en question il faut bien
remettre en question je vais pas
m'indigner contre ceux qui veulent
remettre en question ouais je suis pour
qu'on remette en question ouais
simplement il ya des manières de
remettre en question qui sont plus
intelligentes que d'autres je trouve que
celle qui consiste à déboulonner les
statues elle est nulle
mais là un rôle à jouer dans le monde la
france comme la france ce qui m'inquiète
moi c'est la france
qui est temps d'entendre le général de
gaulle qui dit lola la france elle a un
rôle à jouer oui bah tous les pays ont
un rôle à jouer et la réponse a un rôle
à jouer
qui tient on peut dire à sa son souci
qui vient des lumières liberté égalité
fraternité
et dieu sait qu s'est pas complètement
enfin avant les lumières liberté égalité
fraternité après les lumières une sorte
universalisme pour
tourner vers cialis mme
véritablement intelligent oui bah très
bien je pense que je sais pas si c'est
la france qui est propriétaire de ça
mais enfin quel lequel met ça en avant
et elle essaye de le faire partager
directement inspirée de la philosophie
des lumières quand même oui oui oui ben
est ce que c'est le diversion disputiez
et intelligent à baraka ça
c'est celui qui ne prétend pas
bon moi j'ai une position philosophique
assez ferme l'a vu cela l'universel
c'est toujours l'universel de quelqu'un
ouais bon donc c'est l'universalisme
intelligent c'est celui qui comprend que
il est qu'il appartient à
ce qu'il tienne voilà qu' il n'est pas
eux
il n'est pas mon dial is able tels que
d'accord et que votre adapté en fait oui
et puis que en fait il provient et ils
arrangent ce qu'ils ont ceux qui le
soutiennent l'universel c'est toujours
l'universel de quelqu'un et
alors vrai bon vous voyez bien c'est nos
ancêtres les gaulois dit aux petits
algériens ouais bon ben non donc un
universel intelligence et pas celui là
pour ça c'est une instrumentalisation de
l'histoire par exemple oui tout à fait
ouais on envoie dont on en voit partout
tout le temps ouais ça continue
aujourd'hui
il me semble mais non parce que rompt
avec la mondialisation quand même vous
avez je dirais des réseaux de
communication des d'informations
beaucoup plus ouvert beaucoup plus large
et ce qui fait que ddd on n'est pas
obligé d'accepter tout ce qu on nous
soumet quoi
pour ne pas l'accepter il faudrait
pouvoir juger justement que on en
reviendra que pensez vous de ce que vous
entendez que pensez vous de ce que vous
voyez prenez le pas de recul et
réfléchissez donc c'est pas parce que
c'est communiqué que c'est vrai ou c'est
ouais quand même ouais et la france
aujourd'hui est ce que justement vous
estimer qu'elle elle accomplit elle elle
a trouvé sa place dans cette
mondialisation est ce que elle arriva à
défendre ses propres valeurs à rester
singulière dans ce monde justement
qu'est de plus en plus ouvert plus tôt
mais
les valeurs de la france j'ai du mal à
dire ce qu'est ce que c'est
si je vous dis vous parliez tout à
l'heure d'être 2,2 de la devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
là c'est encore un sens pour moi oui est
ce que ça fonctionne est ce que ça
marche
pas tout à fait mais c'est toujours un
chemin dont la france est pas figée
essentiellement libre égale et
fraternelle non non en revanche que ça
soit quelque chose qu'elle vise et
qu'elle continue à viser en bougeant
ouais oui oui j'espère je ne suis pas
complètement sûr par exemple on parle de
l'égalité
l'égalité hommes femmes est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui à votre avis est une
réalité
aujourd'hui
est ce que vous trouvez que les progrès
qui ont été accomplis justement pour
cette égalité sur suffisamment rapide
que je ne trouve pas ça change rien je
veux dire ce que je crois c'est que il
ya eu beaucoup de progrès évidemment ma
mère ne votaient pas ma mère n'avait pas
de compte en banque ouais moi oui moi je
vois tes j'ai un compte en banque et en
plus voilà je vais vous êtes à
l'académie française là où il y avait
très peu de femmes encore il ya pas très
longtemps et là où il y en avait pas du
tout à la fondation oui oui bon tout ça
change beaucoup ouais est ce que ça
change assez vite sûrement pas ce qu'il
ya encore des inégalités salaires oui
est ce que une femme est toujours libre
de son corps non bon voilà enfin le fait
quand même le droit à l'avortement c'est
quelque chose d'essentiel à disposer de
son corps c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel est ce que vous craignez
redoutiez qui est des départs en arrière
justement aujourd'hui avec une espèce de
remise en question de toutes ces
avancées qui ont été réalisées à la fin
du siècle dernier je pense qu'on peut
toujours craindre mais
je pense qu'on fait bien de craindre
voilà et d'avancer c'est un pays pour
lequel vous pourriez vous battre la
france s'il est si il était en danger
oui mourir
c'est toujours difficile à dire avant
ouais mais peut être présomptueux voilà
ouais mais
ça dépend je pense que oui et en même
temps ça veut dire contre quoi c'est à
dire que mourir pour la france mais
mourir pour la défendre contre quoi ça
ça compte aussi
et et je suis pas sûr que je mourrais
pour la france justement la france c'est
pas trop ça vous gêne
cette emphase oui france mère des arts
des armes et des lois oui ça ça va
encore parce que c'est un beau vers
la france sera toujours la france ça me
gêne
mais je veux bien mourir pour les
français je vais bien mourir pour la
liberté des français et pour la liberté
de ceux qui ne sont pas français ça je
veux bien ouais
on est un peuple très politique
finalement
j'espère oui pourquoi vous dites
j'espère
parce que je pense que sans politique
n'y a pas de peuple
je pense que c'est complètement lié et
je pense qu'on est politique mais qu'on
est aussi un peuple
j'espère aussi on est un peuple
d'artistes on est un peuple de savants
qu'on est un peuple
d'écrivains qu'on est un peuple de
théâtreux j'espère tout ça ouais vous
disiez justement que la langue nous
portait quand même beaucoup oui et on
s'en sert de cette langue oui oui oui
pourvu que ça continue pourvu que ça
continue oui j'étais inquiète claude su
ya des dérives voulait dire
non ce qui enfin
par exemple on parlait de l'académie
française total
elle a fait une vraie protestation et
moi même j'ai protesté plusieurs fois
dans des dans différents journaux sur la
nouvelle carte d'identité oui bon c'est
salaire il doit expliquer en deux mots
oui nouvelle carte d'identité avec une
traduction en anglais oui une traduction
de tous les items tous les items donc
non cename un vrai nom
voilà mais identique à
l'europe demande un certain nombre de
choses elle demande que
un item au moins soit traduit dans une
langue celle qu'on veut de l'europe nous
on a choisi traduire tout en anglais
comme si on pensait que le français
n'était pas à même de porter l'identité
d'un français est comme si pour être
compris pour être compris en france
puisque la carte d'identité française
elle sert en france et en europe ensuite
vous avez le passeport bon
il fallait parler anglais mais c'est
grave c'est grave parce que ça veut dire
que le français ne suffit pas et ça veut
dire que pour toute la francophonie je
vois vraiment pas pourquoi on se
donnerait du mal à continuer à rester
français à parler français à vouloir le
français pourquoi est-ce qu'on file pas
tout de suite dans le globish parce que
en plus quand même ça c'est que
l'anglais bon c'est un peu paradoxal
puisque l'angleterre a acquitté le break
site mais en plus c'est pas de l'anglais
tout ce qu'on veut se développer c'est
du globish du club anglais l'ong
l'aéroport qu'on va dire oui voilà ça
c'est terrible c'est aucune langue
d'accord et maintenant si vous voulez
pour moi le combat il est le même le
combat pour la carte d'identité bon
cette petite chose mais là où ça devient
vraiment grave pour moi qui suis
chercheur cnrs est ce que vous voudrez
qu'ils aient besoin de financement c'est
que pour demander des choses en france
je fasse des dossiers en anglais en
globish ils vont être jugés par des
français mais pas seulement des français
est alors la langue des experts et bien
c'est une non langues le global english
alors ça vous devez être révolté aussi
par le fait qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'universités et d'écoles près le bas
qui font leur enseignement justement en
anglais oui oui je trouve ça stupide
surtout oui c'est pas seulement
révoltant c'est stupide parce que moi
j'ai beaucoup pensé nié par exemple en
chine ouais j'ai eu pas mal d'étudiants
chinois est bien pour eux ce qui est
très important en france c'est le
français c'est la manière de vivre
française c'est de pouvoir aller au
bistrot et c'est c'est pas du foot
anglais parce que pour le sou anglais
non ils vont vraiment rare l'arl donc ya
aucune raison donc on est on est débile
là parce que pour moi si vous voulez
tous ces jeunes étudiants ils veulent
par exemple prenons encore les chinois
oui ils veulent le chinois qui est leur
langue difficile est magnifique et
culturelles etc ils veulent l'anglais
parce que c'est la mondialisation et
puis la lune un troisième pied quelque
chose qui les préserve de ce duo assez
terrifiant et le français c'est là donc
ne pas comprendre ça c'est débile pour
redouter une standardisation du monde
oui au bruit que la france soit victime
de cela en fait finalement lancera
victime et coupable est coupable bah oui
on peut ne pas se laisser faire
évidemment bien sûr qu'il faut pas se
laisser faire il faut pas se laisser
aplanir globalisé
il faut savoir faire avec les
différences c'est pour ça que je prône
tellement la traduction que j'ai fait un
dictionnaire des intraduisible way en
philo ouais mais c'est passionnant c'est
à dire de voir que qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne pas exactement pareil dans
une langue et dans une autre qu'est ce
qui fait qu'ils aient un plus
indifférent et que ce différentiel va
nous apporter c'est ça qui est un cas
qui est vraiment passionnant donc c'est
à nous de faire comme ça et c'est comme
ça aussi qu'on défendra la lune certaine
tension le français est bien sûr on
défend pas le français tout seul
frans on défend toutes les langues
et puis les langues de cultures toutes
les langues de cultures et toutes les
langues sont des langues de cultures
barbara cassin je vois qu'on passe à un
petit jeu qui qui s'appelle le
questionnaire de proust que vous disiez
par exemple si la france était un
paysage ce serait lequel pour vous pour
un paysage
c'est ce que je vois de
de chez moi quand je suis en corse voilà
là ouais c'est ça
je voyais en est où là on est ou encore
cela on est dans le cap à pino un art in
de pino et on a une maison voiliers qui
est juste là sur le bord et là c'est ce
que je vois de ma terrasse sur le mur
est magnifique oui c'est magnifique j'ai
un ami qui m'a dit on va souvent
chercher très loin ce qui est aussi tout
près bouffe la salle bel arrêt
et si c'était une toile la france alors
qu'est-ce que vous choisirez à j'ai
choisi la joconde de duchamp ah oui et à
toute la tradition
léonard de vinci la joconde du louvre
etc et puis il ya la manière de le
mettre en ironie de le retravailler avec
révolte bon et donc cette ironie là qui
est en même temps qu'il fait partie de
l'art contemporain ça j'adore donc voila
et en plus il ya ce jeu sur les mots je
trouve ça quand même magnifique
d'appeler sahel h ou au cul
voyez un bon oeil elle y est loué
vous est révolté par l'ajustement la
l'écriture inclusive à l'écriture
entreprises us et je trouve ça illisible
je trouve ça très pénible bien sûr je
suis révolté
ça va passer quand on va passer d'accord
un auteur à romancier 1
dramaturge poète moi ce que j'aime c'est
la langue j'attends donc par exemple
j'aime racines parce que j'aimerais le
dire ouais j'aime j'aime dire dans un
mois dans un an comme en souffriront
d'un bon j'aime j'aime ça j'aime le son
de racine d'accord j'aurais eu envie
d'être actrice moi j'aurais adoré dire
dire du racine j'aime baudelaire mon
enfant ma soeur à differdange à la
douceur pas tellement vous entendez le
français songe à la douceur d'aller
là-bas vivre ensemble nous aimer ou
entendre les mots sonné oui sonnez
doucement et s'évanouir
entend ma chère entend la douce nuit qui
marche ou voilà ça me plaît ça
personnage historique à marguerite de
navarre à regret de noël d'accord parce
qu'elle est belle et c'est un grand
auteur aussi d'ailleurs c'est un
comptoir enfin il est à bairon wii est
un livre quand même oui et de
remarquable latine vraie femme femme de
françois 1er la soeur la soeur pendant
que la soeur de vincent premier tour de
france un portrait de clouer qui
subliment barker louis où on voit avec
une tête d'ange et ses commenté comme ça
je croise visage un visage d'ange
un choeur d'hommes et un corps de femme
c'est pas mal jolie oui merci barbara
gaza merci à vous
[Musique]